pustules sur le visage crise psychotique
vomissements de sang puis mort au 21ème
siècle la variole a tué jusqu'à un demi
milliard de personnes dans le monde
l'une si ce n'est la maladie la plus
meurtrière de l'histoire elle était
vicieuse lancinante attaquant par vagues
et puis un jour elle a été éradiquée
quand on voit à quel point aux galères
avec le co vide qui risque de devenir
une maladie saisonnière comme la grille
quel a été le secret de nos ancêtres
tout commence au xviiie siècle dans les
rues d'istanbul britannique est curieuse
de ce qu'elle vient de voir des locaux
lui montre comment ni protège des
enfants de la variole on en prend un
contaminé qui a une forme légère on lui
coupe des pustules au couteau on
récupère le puck et on l'a gect dans la
plaie d'un enfant non infectés on
appelle ça la barre ionisation de bras
bras cette technique n'est pas nouvelle
on l'a déjà pratiqué en chine au premier
siècle c'était un peu plus utile quand
même car on soufflait le plus dans le
nez de l'enfant mais moins efficace il
était un peu malade s'en remettaient
plutôt bien et était ainsi immunisés
avis et ça ça n'a pas de prix car en
europe au même moment une personne sur
trois ans mourait en moins de dix jours
les survivants ont été marqués à vie
perte de la vue cicatrices on disait du
visage qu'il était grêlé alors on
l'appelle même sur les adultes et ça ne
se passe pas aussi bien que prévu du
départ du p d'émissions observées car
les personnes vaccinées sont hautement
contagieuse de plus le risque de
développer une forme sévère de la
variole existe certains en meurent alors
pourquoi prendre le risque de me
contaminé volontairement d'une forme
légère au péril de ma vie si j'ai une
chance de ne jamais la trappe et la
population se rebelles ont fait exploser
des grenades dans les salles de barrio
lisation après 100 ans de mario lisation
la conclusion est sans appel ça a empiré
la situation ça a probablement sauvé des
gens oui mais in fine et ça a provoqué
plus d'épidémie que ça na l'a prévenu
car on is les palets inoculé après
l'injection je vous laisse imaginer les
dégâts ce qui va faire reculer la
mortalité c'est la mise au point ou
plutôt la découverte d'un nouveau
procédé mais avant ça puisqu'on parle de
protection contre les virus standing
ovation à notre partenaire norvégienne
où les connaissez forcément si vous
regarder des séries ou des sites à
l'étranger c'est essentiel non vpn
change votre localisation vous fait
passer pour un ordinateur d'un autre
pays ce qui vous des blocs tous les
contenus géo restreint réutilisés sur
netflix pour accéder au catalogue
américain mais leur vpn ça ne sert pas
qu'à ça avec un vpn toutes vos données
passent par un filtre un serveur qui va
anonymisées et sécuriser votre
navigation ça devient très difficile de
vous c'est que ce soit les gouvernements
ou les hackers russes très actif en ce
moment mieux encore cette technologie ne
va pas ralentir votre connexion grâce à
leur technologie north lynx nord vn
incluse au son offre un anti malware
protection anti menace totalement
gratuit pour une durée limitée à partir
de notre lien c'est de la bonne came
donc science trash vous propose une
offre exclusive avec le lien en
descriptions une garantie satisfait ou
remboursé 2 30 jours c'est sans risque
un grand merci à north bay pn pour le
soutien et du coup c'était quoi le
procédé anti variole dont parlait en
1796 un jeune médecin anglais remarques
plusieurs de ses patients ne réagissent
pas la variabilisation ça leur fait même
pas une petite pustules curieux ils
mènent une enquête et découvre qu'ils
ont tous été en contact direct avec la
traite des vaches et que celles ci ont
toutes des pustules sur leurs pis la
variole des vaches celle-ci contaminent
des hommes de façon très bénigne
quelques boutons en main après quoi leur
système immunitaire et préparés ils sont
immunisés contre la variole humaine et
vous savez quel est le nom scientifique
de la variole des vaches la bac sin et
oui c'est de là que vient le mot
vaccination à l'origine c'est
l'inoculation de la vaccine
malheureusement la découverte de jenner
ne va pas faire l'unanimité
ses pairs de l'académie de médecine sont
persuadés que l'ancienne méthode est
meilleur en même temps c'est un business
juteux pour beaucoup de médecins de ce
côté l'église considère que c'est un
péché d'inoculer une maladie d'animal à
l'homme on craint que la vaccination
soit synonyme de mme une autorisation
des vaccinés sont caricaturés en train
de se transformer en mieux homme mi bête
pensais aussi que la variole était une
manière pour le corps d'expier les
péchés de l'enfance de fait si l'on
empêche le corps de développer des
boutons sens et retirer le mal qu'ils se
trouvent dans l'individu alors celui ci
reste un pêcheur toute sa vie aucune
possibilité d'aller au paradis presque
seul jenner peut heureusement compter
sur le soutien du roi george iii il fera
vacciner tout un régiment militaire et
même le prince héritier en deux années
celui qui n'était qu'un jeune médecin de
campagne était en phase de devenir le
père de l'immunologie son ouvrage est
traduit en plusieurs langues et
propagent de procéder dans le monde
entier en france l'introduction du
vaccin a été complexe il fallait
commander du vaccin venus d'angleterre
or il se conserve mal il a fallu trois
voyages donc une première vaccination
concluante soit possible en france ce
qui est cool c'est que l'enfant vacciner
devient vaccine y faire c'est à dire qui
permet la vaccination d'autres personnes
pendant plusieurs semaines pour ça il
doit suivre le docteur il lui servir de
réserve ambulant de plus on peut
remercier napoléon qui rendra la
vaccination gratuite pour les pauvres
est obligatoire dans l'armée il demande
à son entourage de donner l'exemple et
il le fera lui-même avec son propre fils
âgé d'un mois à peine il était tellement
admiratif de gnr qu'il alla jusqu'à
libérer des prisonniers anglais durant
la guerre quand le médecin le lui
demander en 10 ans le taux de mortalité
de la variole passe de 1 5e à 1 centième
le nombre annuel de décès passe de 80
mille à deux mille une réussite totale
pas vraiment ces campagnes de
vaccination on tue beaucoup de problèmes
beaucoup de médecins refusent de se
mettre à la nouvelle méthode car
l'ancien ne demande pas de se procurer
du vaccin qui coûte relativement cher
puis vu que la vaccination est rendue
gratuite pour les indigents les
bénéfices chutent on remarque les
vaccinés développent des hépatites et
des syphilis la raison les enfants
vaccinés faire sont rares car les
parents refusent de laisser leurs
enfants servir de réserve a doctor
durant plusieurs semaines alors les
médecins n'ont pas d'autre choix que de
piocher dans les hôpitaux pour enfants
abandonnés le problème est que ces
enfants vivent dans des conditions
déplorables et qui sont souvent porteurs
de maladies il y avait bien sûr les
superstitions mais aussi des problèmes
plus structurels les propagateurs et
opposants à la vaccination sont souvent
des curés avocats élus forces de l'ordre
instituteur des gens très influents dans
les communes résultat on observe une
carte de france en peau de vache des
communes entièrement vacciner quand
d'autres pas du tout tout dépend de
quelques hommes à force d'utiliser des
enfants maxime y faire on s'est beaucoup
éloigné des vertus du virus originel de
la vache il est moins puissant donc
immunise mois sans alternative les
gouvernements laissent tomber la
vaccination retour à la case départ il
faudra attendre plus de 50 ans pour
trouver une solution à tous ces
problèmes et c'est tout simple arrêté
d'utiliser les enfants vaccinés faire
pour utiliser directement des vaches si
on ne le faisait pas avancer parce que
c'était pas pratique convaincre la
population de relancer la vaccination il
fallait un déclic et il n'a pas fallu
attendre longtemps en 1870 la prusse et
la france entre en guerre la variole
jouent un rôle déterminant dans la
défaite de napoléon iii car une épidémie
se déclare 200000 morts en quelques mois
les quotidiens qui connaissent
l'efficacité du rappel de vaccin ne
craignent pas la maladie sur 8500
soldats contaminé 450 morts côté
français 125000 contaminé 23500 morts
après la guerre la troisième république
impose donc les premières obligations
vaccinales pour mettre un terme au
massacre elles seront général en 1902
cinquante ans après les britanniques au
début siècle les vaccinations se
généralise grâce aux travaux de pasteur
il optimise la découverte de jenner pour
prévenir d'autres maladies et c'est un
succès mais une petite frange de la
population milite contre lorsque
l'institut pasteur est inauguré on
dénonce une usine à virus où l'on
fabrique des maladies pour enrichir les
riches les juifs le grand capital anti
vaccination est antisémite fallait faire
la dernière épidémie de variole
européenne se déclare à vannes en
bretagne en 1955 20% des malades en sont
morts car non vaccinés ou trop
tardivement magiquement 60% de la
population s'est fait vacciner 48 heures
après l'annnonce de l'épidémie la peur
est toujours plus efficace que
l'éducation à l'échelle du monde c'est
en 1958 que l'organisation mondiale de
la santé lance une grande campagne de
vaccination mondiale et au début ça ne
marche pas la maladie continue de se
diffuser même lorsque plus de 80% de la
population est vaccinée pourquoi la
concentration d'habitants au mètre carré
autrement dit les distances à sion
sociale les départs d'épidémie sont si
fréquents qu'il contamine les vaccinés
avant qu'ils soient immunisés sept jours
après l'injection en 1967 le ms décide
donc de changer de stratégie avec la
méthode dite de surveillance endiguement
et là ça marche en 1981 94 ans après la
découverte du vaccin le virus de la
variole est officiellement déclarée
éradiquée de la surface du globe nous ne
sommes pas à l'abri de nouvelles formes
de variole animal qui se transmettrait à
l'homme et qui contrairement à la vache
serait mortel depuis quelques semaines
la variole du singe se propage dans le
monde et bien que relativement bénigne
les effets sont terribles sans compter
le risque de mutation possible
malheureusement on ne sait pas de quoi
demain sera fait en espérant qu'à
l'avenir le monde puisse rencontrer de
nouveaux pasteurs et grands
scientifiques qui puisse nous sauver